[Music]
ma can we get rabbits please
the two-year-old me asked my mom with my
eyes gleaming as we returned from the
petting zoo my mom hated rabbits but she
loved me so fast forward two weeks later
I loved my childhood I remember the
clinking sound of my mother's bangles I
she cooked halwa my favorite dessert and
the irresistible smell from the kitchen
that would tell me when the halwa was
ready her kiss on my forehead
when I was sick the power to heal
everything my father was my hero he and
I would watch cricket matches together
every Sunday we would get super absorbed
in the match and I would swear with my
dad as he would swear during the matches
Kyogre da batsman a water dumb batsman
is he
vivir and inseparable duo he was my
cricket coach my college exam tutor my
career counselor I was the little Simba
learning life skills from my father
Mufasa as a kid my parents for my void
then I grew up I became busy with my
college studies attending the parties my
friends through finding the next big job
earning a few extra dollars of bonus
what started as twice-a-day call with my
parents slowly became once a day then
once in two days then once a week my
parents never said a word whenever we
spoke my father would ask beta he cannot
do son are you doing fine he just wanted
me to be happy
I didn't realize what I was missing
until last December
my father had to undergo a major surgery
the doctors could not guarantee a
success and my father was visibly scared
the day before the surgery gave me a
small diary with everything I would need
to know in case something should happen
to him as the day of the surgery arrived
my father lay on the stretcher as the
doctors moved him into the operation
theater as my hand slipped out of my
father's I saw it air roll down his
cheek it was the first time I'd seen my
father cry
I stood there unable to move and the
doors of the operation theater shut
tight in front of me that moment made me
realize that my father my mother was a
human a human who felt fear a human who
felt vulnerability I stood there
wondering why I never had a reciprocal
relationship with my father he knew all
of my stories but I didn't know any
office I thought of all the questions I
wanted to ask my father feelings I
wanted to share and gratitude I wanted
to convey
what if I never got the chance after an
8-hour long surgery the doctors came out
the surgery was successful I could not
hold back my tears up until this moment
I thought I had a deep relationship with
my parents but now realized I didn't
there was so much we never shared what
matters to us what drives us what scares
us
I wanted more I wanted to have a real
honest and emotional relationship with
my parents one we could be honest about
our feelings one maybe could be
ourselves without the fear of
disappointing each other
the only thing I didn't know was how
fortunately after my father surgery this
happened naturally with him seeing each
other's vulnerable side brought us
closer however I struggled to find the
same relationship with my mother she was
immensely loving and caring with her
actions this is the woman who left a
booming career as a banker so that she
could take care of me but she was also
tough and demanding with her words
especially when it came to doing well in
my exams or getting a good job she had
sacrificed so much for me that I've
wanted to be worthy of her efforts my
fear of disappointing her created an
emotional distance between us in an
attempt to close that distance I started
calling her mother every morning we
would talk about what I had for dinner
how are my classes going what happened
in her day during those conversations I
wondered
am i deserving of her love now I didn't
know economists conversations felt
superficial and cosmetic this was in the
relationship I wanted to build
clearly the phone calls weren't working
so I decided to increase my frequency of
visiting home this summer I skipped a
trip with my friends to spend two weeks
back at home I was spending as much time
as I could with her I wondered am i
deserving of her love now no answer
still I didn't know what will make me
worthy of her love and sacrifices I
didn't know what it takes to have a real
relationship I had run out of ideas last
month during one of our usual phone
conversations I decided to simply ask MA
are you proud of me she was surprised
and replied of course I am you're the
best son in the world
I pressed further ma are you proud of me
she replied
give me a minute she returned with a
poem she had written for me when I was 2
she read out the last stanza how can I
ever thank Almighty for this until and
unless I make him a promise I will make
my son a true human being he keeps the
path of truth I shall be seen a true
human being that's all she wanted
her response changed everything for me I
didn't have to jump through all of these
hoops to be worthy of her love I just
had to be a good human being I felt
closer to my mom 7,000 miles away from
home then I ever felt when we went the
same house a relationship with our
parents shapes who we are I have come to
realize that my super type-a personality
was shaped by my desire to be deserving
of my mother's love how might your
relationship with your parents shape you
by being closer to appearance not only
do we create an opportunity to fully see
ourselves but we also create an
opportunity to separate fact from
fiction separate the truth from the
stories we have been making up no matter
where you are in a relationship with
your parents there are more
possibilities don't set up a few months
earlier I would have said I have a deep
relationship with my parents but now I
know so much more was and still is
possible some
building a real relationship just
require starting with a question my
question was are you proud of me
what will your question be thank you
[Applause]
[Music]